okay right now i'm honored to be joined
by johanna ferris the new gm of
call of duty johanna it's so great to
have you with us here on kickoff live
everyone is so excited about what call
of duty's been doing with all these
seasons and i know uh
looks like next week june 17th season
four
yes we're super excited we're super
honored to be here so thank you first
and foremost to that it's just such an
amazing time for call of duty
we're experiencing such transformational
growth and dynamism across the entire
brand you know from premium title
releases to everything we'll talk about
today
with with warzone with mobile with
esports so it's just
super incredible all the work and shout
out to everybody in the call of duty
family who makes it happen every day
yeah no you've been i mean i know season
three it was like you know rambo die
hard now
who knows what's in store for season
four but you guys you know continually
update the game now with new stuff
uh season four is coming next week what
can you uh
this is first info on it so what can you
tell the fans watching around the world
yeah we're stoked it's jam-packed
with new content across cold war and war
zone you know you've got
new weapons we've got new maps we've got
badass new operators
i'm super excited about the hijacked
gulag we've got expanded zombies content
for everybody who loves that part of
you know the gameplay experience so
we're thrilled and i'm excited to bring
it forward a little bit here today
i know we've got uh the first look world
premiere trailer of uh season four
so uh let's take a look at that now
do what you are told and you get to live
you understand
i knew you were a smart one
secure the site cold war just turned
hard
[Music]
we've
[Music]
i am
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god that looks so fun and one week
away one week away
all right well uh let's move on to uh
you first joined activision to run uh
call of duty esports and we're gonna
talk a little bit now
about uh what is the world series of uh
war zone which is gonna start on june
the 22nd uh
first of all tell us what is world
series warsaw yeah we're super excited
about it it's really
a new way for us to highlight
competitive call of duty you know we've
got great success going with call of
duty league and now we've got
some of the biggest names in gaming
battling it out in verdance
for what will be the biggest prize pool
in warzone
um since it's launched right so um we'll
talk a little bit about what that
entails but custom lobby experience is
150 player
to a side squad so i'm stoked to see how
they
kind of rally here in verdansk yes uh
and coming up uh very soon june 22nd uh
looks like looks like twitch rivals is
going to be a part of this yeah we are
honored to be in partnership with twitch
always right but certainly here with
world series of war zone and
partnering with twitch rivals who's
already done so much
um to really put competitive warzone on
display
so couldn't be in better partnership
there and we're excited to have
everybody tune
in yes uh there is one thing though that
everyone has been talking about online
and that's uh who the captains are going
to be
uh for the structure of uh of the world
trader at least for the first event yeah
um i understand we've uh
getting a little bit reveal here of who
some of the captains are right yeah we
love the first five captains of the
first of many events to come
like i said these are huge influencers
and personalities
in call of duty and they also share our
passion for competitive call of duty
right they really believe
in the promise of world series of war
zone and to really level up what it
means to really battle it out so
uh couldn't be happier with some of
these names many of whom also hail from
the call of duty league family
um and i'm excited to see who kind of
takes the cake here we'll see
i was gonna say they're all be battling
out uh in just a couple weeks on twitch
rivals well it's really exciting uh
to see how much you know call of duty is
growing into this kind of year-round
experience for everyone with so much
more content so we can't wait to see
where you're gonna take it and i know
uh there is a big new mainline game
coming later this year too right indeed
indeed more details to share later on
but uh sledgehammer games is
you know gonna bring forward something
truly incredible so we're excited
all right we tried guys there will come
a time and a place for that all right
johanna thank you so much for joining us
we really appreciate it all right we've